over the years oh let's see what they
run here to
free up steph so 8.7
obviously you need to three if you're
the warriors
damian lee to inbound oh
still looking for steph now draymond's
got it what did he do that for raymond
shot a three with
no five seconds left why you got time
he thought he thought they're probably
gonna foul him right away
and he just anticipated it so i think he
was thinking
he could get three free throws maybe but
deshante murray denied steph the ball
good play by derek white draymond shot
that because he saw white's hand
extended he thought he was going to be
fouled shooting a three
that's unfortunate
so for san antonio
they are going to get away with a game
where they didn't shoot the ball well
at all but they got 11 more shots now
not gonna have long to think about this
because these same two teams are playing
tomorrow yep
at the same time essentially they tried
to set a screen for steph but
didn't really work out so
there are no five-point plays in the nba
and draymond misfires there so the
warriors
they they waste a very good shooting
night they waste a very good defensive
night
they waste a great ubra curry night and
the turnovers will be the reason they
lost the game
and that would be the adjustment for